jeudi dernier dans notre édition de 20h
je vous proposais un entretien
enregistré à Damas avec Bachar al-Assad
au cours duquel celui-ci réaffirmait sa
volonté de réformer à son rythme son
pays qui fut dirigé de façon totalitaire
pendant 30 ans par son père aelassad au
moins en apparence et nous avons pu
constater comme Alain chalverron et
Nadine Picard le culte de la
personnalité est-il en voie de
disparition c'est toujours Hafez elAssad
qui veille à l'entrée du souk Hamadi et
de Damas ce n'est qu'à la sortie du Sou
que l'on trouvera un portrait en forme
de cœur de son successeur et fils
Bachar un an après la mort de Hafez
elAssad rien n'aurait donc changé en
Syrie en apparence non mais le pays
danse aussi une sorte de tango damassen
un pas à droite à gauche en avant en
arrière qui donne finalement une
certaine impression de mouvement ce
journal par exemple à domari né en
février premier journal privé depuis 38
ans était inconcevable autrefois une
sorte de Canard enchaîné qui tape dur et
fort sur les corrompus et les mentalités
sclérosées personne ne vient me dire
ceci est interdit ceci est permis il y a
une loi sur les publications qui
contient en elle-même les limites à ne
pas dépasser par exemple l'armée et les
secrets militaires ou la diffamation
sans
preuve autre signe d'ouverture la
généralisation des paraboles même dans
les quartiers populaires la des clubs
Internet ou la généralisation des
téléphones mobiles la Syrie si longtemps
refermée sur elle-même s'ouvre un peu au
monde pour moi je suis très optimiste
pour l'avenir de moi et de mon pays il
n'aura pourtant échappé à aucun de ces
jeunes gens qu'un coup d'arrêt a été
donné en début d'année à un certain
processus démocratique des dizaines de
forums de discussions étaient apparu ils
ont été fermés il n'en reste plus qu'un
le voici ce forum économique sous haute
surveillance tout est
enregistré le docteur Bachar veut le
changement le problème que nous avons
c'est qu'il y a autour de lui la vieille
garde le vieux
système il bloque sa volonté de
changement alors il va falloir qu'il y
ait un petit choc entre eux de façon à
ce que le docteur Bachar puisse faire
sans problème ce qu'il
veut pour le moment le jeune président
conforte son assise populaire instle ses
propres réseaux le jeu des réformes qui
menaçaient de s'emballer et caresse dans
le sens du poil son armée pour éviter si
possible ce petit
choc impr